[Music]
welcome back to health record where we
talk about whatever we want
whatever we got alex back hey hey guys
hi everybody thank you alex about being
so open about your steroid use again man
that was difficult to be so vulnerable
as [ __ ] man
but i will check it out now actually
every question he says he's a shriveled
up little dick because of steroids
it's probably worth it and you can
probably do way more uplifting and stuff
mike have you ever thought about doing
steroids i have
thought that it's not for me why no it's
for everybody i promise
okay so so um fun fact fun fact um i'm
really
afraid of needles
and i can recount like maybe four times
when i fainted from getting shots at the
doctor no way i think needles are just
as afraid of you probably
and so i want to see michael faint it's
pretty bad it's pretty bad like you know
like when i got my code shot the first
one i fainted in the um the cvs or i
almost fainted because do you tell them
so they start you in in a chair yeah so
i tell them every single time because
it's like if you are lying down the
blood can't rush to your head because
you're already lying down right it's
already there it's what it is and so
like but the thing is you can still feel
uncomfortable uncomfortable have you
ever
fainted and then woken up and then saw
the needle and faint again
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh
a helmet and like pads on like you're
going rollerblading no but i want to try
that next time you should but um
that's pretty great michael the [ __ ]
hockey goalie so you know i pass out
when i see needles
i tell them that and they're like yeah
it's pretty common is it a seeing or the
feeling it's the thinking about it i
think which is really hard so before you
get the tech like before you get the
shot you're are you just like a wreck
are you like sweating or you just like
nervous yeah like um because you know so
like for the kobe try you get this kind
of ski you had to schedule it in the
very beginning and so like i scheduled
up my shot and like i was thinking about
it and then i was trying not to think
about it but then like in the days right
before the shot i was like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there's about to be a needle going
into my arm right and i was just like oh
i don't know if i could do this but you
know i wanted to get the shot obviously
and i like that
what about what about like when you get
a tooth stuck did you ever get wisdom
teeth pulled i have you pass out there
too
um i think i told the doctor so they
gave me um ana's like full body or is it
i was i was out gone cold so i don't
remember any of that this might be a
very stupid question but if you see a
needle like a movie
oh i can't watch that like any kind of
scene when they're doing heroin i'm just
like oh [ __ ] you know like i can't watch
this at all
okay do you have your back a little i
think you're a junkie in the movie
tripping
you know like at the beginning of uh was
that train spotters or something yeah
yeah like i was like [ __ ] i can't watch
this anymore i'm done with this one to
have your back a bit every time i'm
getting on a roller coaster and when
it's like before anything's really going
on i'm like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] dude
i'm like participation huh yeah when i'm
going up or whatever or on the tower of
terror thing when it's like going up i'm
like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] why am i doing
this yeah i'm the same way kind of it's
the worst part of it i don't know what i
can faint on i don't like anything when
i got my first shot i was like
by your lip like it reminded me of you
know when i used to do it i was like oh
[ __ ] that feels kind of good hey
remember that no i i mean yeah i don't
know what i can faint on you don't
really like uh roller coasters either i
don't but i went on my first roller
coaster in like 16 years last saturday
why don't you like where was it are you
afraid of heights i was because when i
was like a kid like you know when
internet youtube's find anything that
you wanted i think when we were like 10
or 9 me my brothers were searching like
roller coaster crashes oh
cool how specific the rollercoaster
crashes something we all want to watch
and then so like we were watching like
these things come off and people flying
off so i was just terrified of it and
then like when i was like 11 we had like
a family trip to six flags and i when i
i guess on the most basic one it has one
loop it's like the oldest one and like i
was so terrified i've never been on a
roller coaster since the best thing
about that is it looks terrifying but
the loop is actually the easiest part of
any roller coaster the drop is the worst
why is this so easy well because there's
so much force holding you down yeah that
you feel it and you're like i feel like
a baby like all wrapped up in a blanket
and that that's true because so it was
at disneyland when i went on that one
the their main one right oh the
incredibles one right yeah it was like
after after the loop it felt like even
when we were going it felt like so heavy
like i was getting pulled down it was
weird when you're upside down like a big
old even after though like yeah i was
like damn i remember when i was a kid i
was able to go back to back to back and
try to hit every single ride and i'd be
like having the time of my life right
and then like
i think like later on like college we
went we went to six flags and then we
tried to do the same thing and i got a
headache and i was like i don't know how
i used to do this like i got dizzy
like i was like what the [ __ ] happened
to my mind your balance is [ __ ] off
when you get old like if i don't hit the
bag for a while right and i hit the bag
my head will throb a little bit and i
was talking to uh taika's jiu jitsu
coach who rolls all the [ __ ] time
he's always upside down and whatever he
started taking salsa lessons with his
wife and he says like after salsa he has
like [ __ ] vertigo and [ __ ] oh my god
dude you're [ __ ] spinning upside down
all the time like that's just crazy
you're brain shaking all the time yeah i
got a weak ass [ __ ] brain dude he's
like salsa [ __ ] me up
like what the [ __ ]
i don't know i'm trying to think
do i have any fears i want i don't want
it to be like i find out later you know
like we're going to go fishing or
whatever and i don't want to find out
like oh my god [ __ ] fish you know or
something like that i could probably
faint if i was in the water and i saw
some big ass like whale coming towards
oh my god
the [ __ ] out with that or if like
there's a bear
like and he's like right here on me i
probably faint
you should that's not bad at all
there's this really funny viral video
it's not really funny it's kind of more
scary but these guys in a boat and a
bear is swimming after them
like like just you screaming at these
people in the in a boat and it's like
swimming pretty fast and the head is
biggest oh my god it's a big ass [ __ ]
bear bears are bare they can run
sideways like at 30 miles an hour
sideways there's like shuffling yeah
that sounds too funny
that's like an obese man spreading at
you i think a bear can run like almost
30 miles an hour sideways oh
out of bear bro now [ __ ] that bears bear
okay i could probably faint yeah if
there was a bear in front of me probably
it would faint have you guys seen that
bobcat [ __ ] the guy was hiking and he
saw the bobcat babies and then the mama
bobcat came and he was like oh no no no
no [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah oh yeah it was
like chasing him for like two miles
oh
but he he had the energy to [ __ ]
record dude yeah he was recording the
whole time
but that was that i don't think i was
even a bobcat that was like a cougar
that was like bigger than a bobcat it
was huge cats are small aren't they yeah
what would you do like i don't know if
i'd have the time to get down grab a
rock and [ __ ] chuck it at him
you know that's scary i'm putting the
phone away i'm gonna find the biggest
branch i could find
he's recording the whole thing yeah
there's some syringes on me i'm gonna
get a rock and a big branch so i got
like a long distance weapon and then a
[ __ ] shorter one yeah yeah
shorter range i feel like because you
were in the military you probably know
how you probably have the proper
training to kind of attack but for me i
don't prepare for a wild animal
but i feel like the boy scouts probably
prepare disaster the long bear attacks
like a sword you know like a dagger i
don't know who bears fighting
oh
uh nobody really wins it actually gets
just just dispersed oh
wow you guys want to see
they're still at it it's being filmed
pretty well fights are so entertaining
and then the guy's car is getting towed
too oh my god oh my god yes the video
the video is on a gimbal live fight
comment let's go
uh awful trying to fake him out with him
yeah he's trying to fake him out with
some kicks what else bart what else well
the guy in the orange t-shirt i like
people's uh uh fight stance there's a
lot of [ __ ] ass-ness dude mr miyagi
says never turn your back to the
opponent man
he's getting his car now wait wait wait
that guy doesn't even look like he's in
a tow truck uniform
but he's like
he's a tow guy he's like don't tow my
car
dude look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
and hey remember they run slowest
downhill too
[ __ ] imagine apple coming after you dude
you're dead wait who's he chasing
this guy's zoomed in as hell too by the
way because he's not even freaking out
on me wait he was really cool he's in
the car
yo that's scary
type in russian grandma chase's bear oh
[ __ ] yeah that shit's dope russian they
say when you're a bear's attacking you
you're supposed to get really big as big
as possible yeah i don't trust you guys
see that bear that was eating a sandwich
with the family
i didn't seen that recently actually
yeah it's crazy you're supposed to make
yourself as big as threatening as
possible so you make the bear think like
hmm the second guess like okay this
isn't a prey and it's predator and you
just take your chances are you sure it's
called russian grandma chase's bear that
sounds like a joe title
on pornhub or youtube do you see
yeah exactly no it's like a grandma
chases bear maybe it's not russian i
found one of uh bears attacking cyclists
no it's a grandma
she she chases a bear where was the bear
on like a brick wall no it was in the
backyard and the ground was like
and then the [ __ ] bear goes oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] have you guys ever seen a
bear a wild bear like in person today's
video is brought to you by hello fresh
america's number one meal kit oh man
number one at first i was very skeptical
because i am a food snob
i like to do my own research my own
recipes my own things right yeah it's
either that or i'm going to the world
famous mcdonald's or something get some
junk food whatever yeah i rather eat
that than some kind of
cookbook meal okay
but what i realized is this is something
revolutionary it is different they send
you all the ingredients that you need
and they also give you a quick little
recipe that you can follow and what i
thought was like you know what this
reminds me of legos when i was a kid
okay like i wanted to build exactly what
was on that picture of the box of the
box right and that's what hellofresh is
it's food legos you make it at home
you're just like oh my god i don't have
to go to the store anymore
i don't have to even like spend all this
money anymore because it's per meal if
you live alone you don't need to buy all
these groceries it's gonna go to waste
you know exactly what i'm talking about
you got mold in your fridge right now
i could already see your fridge it
probably smells like that and you only
have beer in there that's true and you
know what i like about it
you know you ever feel ashamed to go to
another culture supermarket
you're like ah
i'm asian i can only go in here but i do
want to try food from over there what's
cool is they got food from all sorts of
different cultures so you can try
secretly in your own home to see what it
feels like to be scandinavian one day or
italian one day or spanish one day you
could try all or if you are spanish you
could feel like oh i wonder what it
feels like to be thai today make
yourself some pad thai and everything is
pre-measured and it's fresh and it comes
right to your door and you don't have to
worry about it and you can cook it and
you can enjoy being that culture for
that one delicious meal so if you want
fresh pre-measured food that comes
straight to your house go to
hellafresh.com
off the record 14 to get up to free
14 meals can you believe that 14 meals
for free that's seven days that's a
whole week
go to hellofresh.com off the record 14.
wow america's number one meal kit hello
fresh like a cub but not like a full
grown i was driving up on to you know
where chantry flats is yeah yeah uh i
was driving up and there's like that one
point where you get where you can see
all the way up the mountain you can see
the whole road how do you drive
up to chantry flats it's sierra madre
boulevard and you just go all the way oh
okay yeah and um as i got to that point
i saw like a group of people and i saw
this little brown thing which i thought
was a dog right so as i got to the spot
i was like uh like these people are
still over here i'm like looking for
this dog and i'm like parked in my car
and like say this is like the the
divider big-ass bear just comes and just
like
and i just drove away i didn't even tell
anybody
that's not what happened here check this
[ __ ] out is this the grandma one no this
is another this went viral oh yeah
it was like a girl and then her dogs oh
yeah i remember this one
oh my god
it looked like my asian mom character
dude
i thought it was an old lady but it was
i guess it was like a younger girl i
wonder what happened to the
the dog like if it hurt it looked okay
they might have got sweat because they
got big claws some are watching a trail
of
running after it so i think it's all
right she said the dogs were fine but
she broke her pinky or something i
watched the news so she broke her pinky
yeah from pushing the bear that's it
oh wow she did something to her hand
i think there's like
like different kinds of bears that are
more aggressive too like some of them
they're like yogi bear he's like the one
that doesn't want you to smoke in the
forest but then some of them are like
[ __ ] up smokey the bear right yeah
smokey the bear yogi bears the honey
bear huh no smokey the bear's the hungry
bear yeah
he tries to eat people's picnics yeah oh
wait but who's the one that doesn't want
that's baloo
no the thing that he doesn't want the
forest to burn smokey smoky yeah only
you can prevent force okay i don't know
dude i think that's that's a care bear
that's mcgruff i think yeah that's a
caribbean rough wait what care bears are
the ones for to prevent before forest
fires yeah i thought that was smoky the
best smokey bear's a hungry bear and
then um yogi bear is the the forest fire
the gay man
and then i think the scariest bears are
grizzlies yeah i've watched so many
youtubers biggest and the most
aggressive where are they at
like what areas mountains mountains yeah
i don't know i want something all i know
i had a i had a client once tell me that
you can smell a grizzly a grizzly bear
from like almost like a half a mile away
because they stink because they smell
super bad
yeah so they like she told me if you
ever go camping like in i forget where
she had said but all of a sudden you
start smelling something really bad
she's like always like pack up your
stuff and get in your cars because it's
most likely a grizzly bear coming
so that's scary intense i sleep in trees
every time someone says go camping i'm
like where is there bears because i'm
good i'm out
damn that's crazy where you want to go
no desert either [ __ ] you it's too dry
it has a nosebleed city over there you
get bit by snake
that's one of the most annoying things
like growing up in boy scouts when you
go camping in the mountains where you
know there's like there's known bears
there you always have to do this thing
called like a bear bag so you take
anything that's scented or whatever
so it could be your shampoo it could be
your snacks your food yeah you got to
put it in a bag throw it over tree
that's super high and then raise it up
in the sky so the bears can't get after
it and then tyler will not
and uh and then you get it in the
morning because then there's like horror
stories of bears just going straight
into the tents and just pulling kids out
by their sleeping
down the mountain dude
so that's something that you always have
though they can open the zipper yeah
they can open doors they open the zipper
[Laughter]
there was this viral video that i saw
recently uh you know the bear traps that
they have the big metal bins yeah they
release one and the guy set up his
camera and the bear just runs out and
swipes at the camera that's just crazy
they're so powerful actually like break
your neck but why do they gotta look all
[ __ ] cuddly and [ __ ] because the only
thing i think about is petting the [ __ ]
out of them and giving them a hug they
do look like they'd be fun to hug i know
right it's so fun but they just watch
bear videos all [ __ ] day dude they
look like they're just hugging all day
dude you see a video of habib uh
wrestling with a bear as a small child
no way yeah dude
look at that literally it looks like a
husband with a teddy bear and uh bears
know how to wrestle like they they like
they do real wrestling moves there was a
video of this asian dude i think it was
in china or something he jumps into a
zoo
and the panda bear comes out and he's
[ __ ] with the panda bear and the
panda bear is like laying down the panda
bear gets up and shoots a single leg on
him what and like is putting weight on
top of him and the guy's freaking out
he's on the ground he's like i don't
know what the [ __ ] to do here if you tap
the bear will he let go he'll respect
the top
but he was like he he had him in side
control and he was like he was stuck
yeah that's what arm board i'm here yeah
dude imagine a panda bear with a [ __ ]
armbar
a silverback or a bear
oh [ __ ] what kind of bear like a full-on
fight grizzly or silverback it's like a
weapon right no i'm talking about the
animal versus the animal i know but
silverback's punch yeah they punch
i think silverbacks are pretty fun
because i feel like bears they got claws
and they got teeth so they got better
weapons but uh
a silverback actually has a stronger
bite than a grizzly bear does it no but
they they don't have this they don't
have the chiseled teeth man they do they
got they got two big fangs they got some
little chunks [ __ ] pets and they got
long fingernails and they got hands like
humans too so yeah but then like weapons
they might have arm reach but then bear
got height
bark baber's got height and weight yeah
they're like 12 feet tall can break down
how a bear could beat a a gorilla just
uh through wrestling bro just better
refined technique
um i think a gorilla could win if he
picks he's going to pick up a branch i
think well gorilla also got broken down
defense because they got short legs oh
yeah
what about the reach the upper body
though the upper body torso
i don't know that's actually more pretty
that's pretty tough bears can't box that
good i think i think gorillas might be
stronger and greater
and on their back feet a lot longer
and this is how roman emperor started
the gladiators
it happened something somewhere like
this like we could never do it obviously
like oh we could make it happen
we can get people to pay and show up no
way like a [ __ ] giraffe to come fight
a gladiator or like whatever right not
gonna do anything
i just gotta sit there and the giraffe
one every time hey giraffes are have you
ever seen giraffes fighting each other
they [ __ ] hit each other on the head
dude
yeah but there's like this video too of
like a big silverback that's like
leading its troop right and uh he's
walking by like the the people that are
there and he grabs one of the guys pants
leg with just like his fingers and just
start dragging him like it's nothing oh
yeah that's how strong they are it's
crazy
i found giraffes fighting so i'll be
damned
what about gorillas fighting nah
damn
damn they're taller than a tree
oh [ __ ] look he's like they're trying to
look off and then i don't know where it
goes
trying to catch them slipping huh oh
yeah we're done we're definitely
kind of funny you think they're going to
stop fighting great
like two grandmas at a [ __ ] black
friday sale dude it's weird because like
normally animals will like growl and
like you can see their teeth they're
just like
holy god [ __ ] they need these to stay
up otherwise you're gonna come from
anyway giraffes are just horses aren't
they those big long neck horses
nah dude they're like horses and like
zebras or some [ __ ] they're combined bro
zebras are sustainable horses is what
they are yeah yeah that's exactly
cannibal barcode horses
mike what do you what kind of fun facts
do you know about uh giraffes
um i don't know anything about giraffes
but i did read a fun fact about zebras
about how
compared to normal horses they get
bitten by mosquitoes way less because
they have that you know the scan the
stripes yeah i can't see the mosquitoes
dude i don't know maybe the mosquitoes
can't see them as well i don't know or
maybe they just don't like stripes
that's dope yeah it's a fun fact of the
day that is a very random fun fact you
know why no why does no one ride uh
zebras
they're
probably too wild yeah they're too wild
they're not domestic horses are pretty
wide or they're probably thinner i feel
like they're thinner than another
smaller yeah yeah you're right
zebras
if anybody wants
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't want no regular horse
he just runs a zebra
hmm
[Music]